after Kylie became a mom how does that
friendship change don't know for me when
my friends have babies it's just like
our worlds are so different
well I always remember you know Kylie
saying she always wanted to be a mom and
you know that she really felt like
that's what she was meant to do in life
so I feel like it didn't really change
like Kylie is so mothering and she's
just such a sweet loving person in
general and I just think that now is
just more okay cosmetics and then are
you spoiling stormy Osram you suck you I
saw her for her first birthday and they
did the whole Carnival a store hop it
was amazing now she's the sweetest thing
ever I got her a little I always go to
sleep with a star projector oh when I
fall asleep it like lights up my room
that makes it look like they're stars
and so I got her the same thing oh
that's a I thought she would like to
fall asleep on it that's really
thoughtful all seems to be well for long
time pals Pia Mia and Kylie Jenner
though they haven't stepped out much
together in recent years blame it on big
life changes kylie is a new mom and Pia
is starring in the highly anticipated
romantic drama after
truth or dare okay truth are you a
virgin I'll do dare I dare you to make
out with her I'm done playing this game
your character in particular wasn't
supposed to be a woman can you talk
about when you found out that you were
gonna be playing Tristan yeah well I
auditioned for the movie and then after
I auditioned for it I checked out after
and check out the books and I saw
Tristan was the guy in the books and I
just thought it was so cool that they
made her a girl for the movie and I
placed F's girlfriend and the LGBTQ
community is so supportive of me in
music and just in my life and so I'm so
happy to be able to you know play
bringing that to life yeah yeah bring it
to life a ton and Pia's new song bitter
love is featured in the film
[Music]
how did you feel being able to cross
those two worlds as an actress and a
singer it was so cool I mean I loved you
know the bodyguard when Whitney Houston
had her song and did that and Lady gaga
did the same thing and so having better
love be part of after it's so special to
me
this song means a lot to me and has a
lot like emotionally attached to it for
me so after is the perfect place for it
and the fans the reaction they've had
it's just so perfect because it does
represent hard and in Tesla's
relationship and my bitter love is
hopefully hearing it too and yeah just
had to get this emotion out are you
drawing inspiration from your own
personal experience with heartbreak in
your song or what can you say to that
for me bitter love is about you know a
relationship that was happening and now
it's not happening and I want it to be
back to where it was and I'm trying to
be patient and I don't know if you know
maybe it just wasn't the right time or
maybe this person wasn't meant for me
but I feel like you know this is my true
love and we just happened at the wrong
time and so it's that painful struggle
of like having this passion but it's
just the relationship isn't there and
you want it to be whenever oh yeah and
I'm so curious to like look back on this
and see if I was right like if this
person really is you know my one
absolutely I see